Green Chemistry,
its role in,
uh,
advancing sustainability,
dealing with health issues and dealing with environmental issues.
Um,
so did you get the benefits of chemistry and chemicals in the world without the
adverse consequences?
21 words.
It's the definitely one sentence definition of green chemistry.
Green chemistry is the design of chemical products and processes that reduce or
eliminate the use in generation of hazardous substances.
So what teaching a course on this subject,
there are journals devoted to the subject.
There are international networks,
research networks in 35 countries around the world.
Our presidential awards on the subject,
and I could go on and on and on.
These 21 words better means something.
If you're going to define,
uh,
an area of focus
like that in one sentence.
So Green Chemistry.
So I'm going to just spend a few minutes about this.
So first of all,
it'll sound like I'm joking.
People think I'm joking when I'm talking about Green Chemistry.
Now these green,
everything green,
this,
green that,
but back in 91,
uh,
it wasn't,
it wasn't that way.
And people said,
how did you come up with this crazy name green chemistry at the time?
And they think,
I'm joking when I say that,
you know,
green of course ever been an hour thinks of conjuring up images of,
of the natural environment.
Green tree is green leaves and everything else and it's synonymous with
environmental types of issues.
But in the u s green is also the color of our money.
And so how do you break that old myth that we've talked about,
which is that if you go into have environmental improvement,
make things more sustainable,
it has to cost more and it has to be an economic drain.
How do you instead meet the economic goals and the environmental goals
simultaneously?
How do you align those two things so that market drivers become a catalyst for
doing things in a sustainable way?
And that's one of the things that's at the essence of green chemistry.
And quite frankly,
one of the reasons why it has such widespread adoption.
Um,
and we can talk a lot more about that,
but the word chemistry and this chemistry is the design of chemical products and
processes.
So when we're talking about chemistry,
we all know that we're not talking about a department in a university.
We're not talking about a particular industry sector narrowly defined as we've
been talking about.
We're talking about everything that you can see,
touch and feel at the most fundamental level.
How do you understand the molecular basis of,
of our,
uh,
products and processes to make them more sustainable?
Okay.
So,
um,
products and processes that's in this why?
Because really what we're talking about and what's absolutely key is the
lifecycle.
I've talked a little bit about the life cycle.
We're going to talk a lot about the life cycle and just a few minutes,
but is it possible to make something that's benign or therapeutic and
beneficial,
a product
that is made in an absolutely agregious manufacturing process?
Is that possible?
Yeah.
Does anybody want to remind me about pharmaceuticals?
How much waste per pound of product on average for pharmaceuticals,
one ton of waste per pound of product produced on average across the life cycle.
Okay.
Uh,
you'll see different numbers.
Different numbers is because you're going to get variability from drug to drug.
But the variability is also because
if you measure across the lifecycle from the origins of the feedstock for the
under the product,
that could be very different if you say,
oh,
well we're measuring from gate to gate when you only what's happening within our
manufacturing facility.
So you'll see different numbers,
but a ton of ton of waste per pound product is a good general general measure.
Hold it.
That could be a lifesaving drug.
Yeah,
but you made it in a way that was tremendously polluting.
What about the opposite?
Can you have a tremendously efficient a manufacturing process but brings about,
um,
uh,
acutely lethal product?
Sure.
Absolutely.
The synthesis of mustard gas,
one of the horrible nerve agents have a worldwide one is one of the most
perfectly efficient chemical syntheses manufacturing process that you could
imagine.
That's,
you could argue that it's about as close to zero waste as many of our
manufacturing processes get.
Okay.
So in need to look across the life cycle.
So we're talking about products and processes that reduce or eliminate the use
and generation.
Okay.
So can you reduce waste
with green chemistry?
Absolutely.
Right.
Can you make a process more efficient using green chemistry?
Absolutely.
Is that where it ends?
Absolutely not.
Again.